hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video we're
gonna analyze your place guys thank you
very much for those who participated in
the trading games that we are having on
discord for free of course so today
we're gonna go through the top five
plays so we're gonna analyze bitcoin amc
cvs and lucid let's get into it
[Music]
alright so first thing thank you very
much for those who played this week we
received around 15 plays done by around
10 players so i know that you guys can
do better than this so please go come
those who are on discord you know where
to find the form for those who are not
there yet we're gonna maybe uh make it
available for everyone very soon give us
some time but once again go there fill
the form give me your place guys it's
for free we don't know about the prices
yet for this month it's 300 us dollar
for the first and zoom meeting with
gabrielle and myself for the second one
and for this month the more players we
have the better the prices so we're
gonna probably announce that next week
depending on how many of you are playing
so let's analyze this ranking so only
put the top five guys because i don't
want to show the ones
that are just not making great plays for
now i think it's more interesting to see
the ones that had good reactions so
first tim he's the winner he went on
bitcoin so he was a buyer at 57 500 and
the stop was at 55 000 what he was
seeing is a divergence and elliott wave
so let's go quickly through that we're
gonna analyze
bitcoin so
he saw a divergence so elliot wave i
agree because this is what i'm doing so
we're on the fourth wave and he was
trying to buy the bottom so he bought
here so it's a very nice buying level
and he saw a divergence so divergence
you guys know what i'm looking for we're
looking for lower market making lower
lows and the uh momentum increasing so i
don't i don't see the momentum going
higher on daily timeframe i'm gonna zoom
in i'm not seeing the momentum going
higher on the first time frame
okay here you go bro okay i'm still
trying to find
where this momentum so
i don't know where you saw the
divergence bro right the divergence is
whenever the market moving low lows and
the magdy making higher so maybe he's
seeing
it with the rsi let's let's check
okay no bro i don't see a divergence but
we still have a bounce and right now let
me give you my view guys on bitcoin
because this is interesting as well so
he bought here on the deep uh well done
he got a bit lucky because this deep
didn't last long but he is still in his
train so congratulations to him
and right now guys uh what will you you
can see my take on bitcoin is that we're
gonna rally i think we're gonna buy uh
very soon maybe today or tomorrow i have
a breakout here i was waiting for this
correction to be done we went to the
38.2 retracement of third wave guys so
very quickly i show you my view we
corrected 38.2 so this is a valid level
for the false wave correction that
usually goes to the 38.2 so it's
actually a very classic situation and
now we broke out above this trend line
right the blue trend line that is here
we broke out above and now we even had
the retests and we are going higher so i
think guys bitcoin might do new all-time
highs next week let's see now next play
i'm gonna analyze the number two who is
anxious so anxious savings so anxious
savings did a nice performance of eight
percent he was doing a trade on amc with
leverage times five so he entered at
38.8 he got in and he has no target he's
just keeping it and he saw low volume
support resistance so i did amc already
but let's quickly have a look at it
again and he's right guys low volume
means that we are going lower on low
volume so this is kind of you know a
divergence when you go lower it's not
that divergent it's just showing that
the move on the downside is not powerful
and he supports around 33 i guess 33.5
so he got in
he has no targets so i don't know if
we're going to keep his plays for next
months let's see but he's in his number
second so congratulations to him i can
give you my view again but guys i posted
a video yesterday about amc i see a
long-legged dodgy candle which to me is
showing the bulls are trying to take
back control so i think we might see a
reversal coming this week then third
play
so
g-star bay is
number three on the podium so
congratulations
uh to her i would say
i think so maybe him we're gonna find
out i don't have the nickname here so
next time please give me your nickname
so that i know how to call you so this
player was in cvs
and we analyzed that already but let's
have a look at it again quickly guys cvs
how is it looking
so here the reasons were that we had a
breakout we had a new high we had a nice
consolidation before
is it and i agree so
the reasons were here are the reasons i
can see everything you guys give me new
high consolidation support resistance
macd cross okay indeed we have here the
macd turning uh positive on the 15th of
october so it's quite early
so maybe the mighty cross is under four
hours okay i'm not sure
why the magic cross has been used here
because it was
two weeks ago but fair enough okay maybe
she was just feeling we are bullish now
because it was green for 10 days fair
enough we have the breakout a
consolidation below i agree this is a
nice consolidation area guys okay that
gives energy to the move that is about
to come
and we make a new high above this level
right here about 87 so guys whenever you
have uh it's a very interesting play
once again whenever you have a breakout
after consolidation making a new high
this is already enough signals to get in
uh here we also have the macd that is in
positive territory but usually when you
have those three the macd will always be
green we are looking good we have
resistance around 90 so
does she want to take profits she's
taking profits at 91 so once again we've
gone through this
and i think it's a perfect uh play it
would
work i think she's gonna be in profit
soon
so let's see if we keep display for next
month once again guys come there if
you're already on this code just click
on this link it's very easy to fill the
form i'm going to show you again at the
end of this video but it takes you one
minute and it's very i think interesting
for you for me and for everyone to see
the reasons why you do your trades so
last one i want to analyze is lucid uh z
germans was in amc but he he bought a
bit higher at 35
so and he didn't use leverage so he's
number four and lucid so brother stone
urn brother you
were about to make a beautiful trade but
you didn't get in so let's analyze first
the reason nice consolidation before the
move company news
and here okay you're explaining a bit
well let strong move up okay let me
check here exactly okay so delivery
starting in late october october for
lucid motors good news breaking tesla
record for signal charge okay has led to
strong move up but always rejected at
trendline due to lack of delivery so far
deliveries might possibly break
trendline after months of consolidation
after the by the rumors of the news
earlier this year i expect a strong move
up to 33 if break trend line and slide
pull back blah blah blah then fill up
the gap okay so very good analysis
unfortunately bro you didn't manage to
be in the trade
so let's check
you entered the order on the 24th of
october and the lowest level was 24.7
bro you missed that
for just a little you were at 40 24.1 so
so sorry for that brother you could have
been number one but you're not in the
trade you didn't get executed so let's
analyze lucy then let me give you my
view as well i pretty much agree with
everything that has been said 24th of
october okay it's on the 25th
how about a pen in the ass just
bro you were right on it
it was exactly the good trade you rather
just before breakout
nice very nice thread congratulations uh
i wanted to buy here as well on my hand
i was looking for the breakout we didn't
have the breakout for me that could help
me to get getting this trade i missed it
for a little as well uh so right now
what happens guys so we went to 35 that
was resistance yesterday we make new
highs and we finally closed below so
what i was saying is that all this area
is a
resistance area okay we have the gap
here so
we might fill the gap
i think we might go to the 50 area i
don't believe we might go really higher
right now guys but maybe later because
we have all these back holders that are
gonna take profit so if we are to go
higher it would be maybe something like
this and then maybe like that okay and
this would be as usual guys a one two
three four five all right
so this would make sense okay why not
but it's gonna take a thing more time
and i
of course check the option market guys
to get information about where we're
gonna see this explosive movements on
the upside because you guys know that
whenever we have gamma market makers are
buying
shares
to hedge their positions
because they are selling calls to retail
investors
it's growing
is
it let me check if i have lucid
okay it's the first time
i
put it here but yesterday we didn't have
a check that before we didn't have all
this uh options around the 50 strike so
the gamma is growing so i turn more
bullish all right the more options i'm
gonna see here the more i'm gonna
believe in the fact that if we get
closer to this level once again the
moves are gonna be amplified and we're
gonna see strong moves guys around this
level it's true in both directions so if
we start to move higher it should
continue and if we start to move lower
it should continue as well so
right now we are above 35
so it's quite bullish to me let's see
once again i would be careful in this
area i think they're gonna be a lot of
back holders uh but if we manage to stay
above 35 that's looking quite good to me
it might take maybe some time but
eventually we might break out above 50
that is for me the level to watch i
don't really watch the all-time high i
think that the gap upper band is uh the
level that we need to break for best to
capitulate so let's see what's happening
here once again i'm kind of neutral in
this area below 35 it's not looking
great and above 50 it's looking like uh
the squeeze is on and let me show you
how to fill the form again for those who
are interested so you can find the form
here guys trading games on the gold
level
all right you just go here form to fill
to play so look at that guys it's
extremely easy
you have the rules here so you can read
it you just enter your discord id your
nickname your ticker here so once again
for example lucid okay so i want to buy
it so long okay at 36 exit level i take
profits just below the 49 i have a stop
loss at 33
i'm gonna use times five leverage uh the
reason it would be a retest
of the breakout
and
i agree i don't give any charts and
that's it okay and then you just click
on submit so guys very easy it takes one
minute come play once again it's gonna
be interesting to see if i agree with
your reasons or not and for me it's
interesting to see what type of trading
you like to do so that's it for today
and once again if you enjoyed this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore
i'll see you guys